WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ON AGRICULTURE
HEARING.
WE ARE WAITING --
FOR ONE OF OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US SO THAT WE
CAN START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
BOB THIS IS A PARTICULARLY BUSY
DAY AND WE'RE GONNA TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THROUGH ALL THE
BELLS IN A TIMELY MANNER SO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE HEARING --
WE HAVE THE SIX BELLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY AND THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HEARD IN FILE ORDER IN
LEAST THAT'S THAT CONCEPT --
THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
IS IS EACH AUTHOR WILL HAVE NO
MORE THAN THREE WITNESSES AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE TABLE AND THE
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE NO MORE
THAN THREE WITNESSES INSPIRED
TABLE AND THEY'LL BE GIVEN. TWO
MINUTES EACH.
AND THEN --
AFTER THAT WE'LL HAVE.
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFY THEMSELVES
FOR THE RECORD AND TO GIVE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION ON
THE BELTS [inaudible]
SO -- SEEING
AS HOW WE DON'T HAVE.
THE SENATOR HERE AT MISTER FLORA
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING A BILL TODAY
THAT'S NUMBER SIX ON THE AGENDA
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE THAT
UP THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU SERVE
TWO FUNCTIONS THAT THEY WERE
REALLY HAPPY YOU'RE HERE.
AND THAT IS NUMBER SIX ON THE
AGENDA WHICH IS S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE CANNABIS
CULTIVATION COUNTY AG.
COMMISSIONER REPORTING.
I THINK THE AMERICAN SHARED
MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT'S THE
FORM.
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH CENTER
CANNELLA PROVIDES WILL OF
OPPOSITION A PARABLE.
IT IS ALSO A SMALL SIZED DOG
WORDS.
GOOD FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CULTURE.
WELL THE CURRENT STATE LAW DOES
NOT PROHIBIT THIS ACTION THIS
BILL PROVIDES A LEVEL OF
ASSURANCE THAT FOR COUNTIES THAT
ARE CONSIDERING DOING SO.
AB BEEN RELUCTANT WITHOUT
STATUTORY AUTHORIZATION CANVASES
GROWING IN MANY COUNTIES ACROSS.
S. CULTIVATIONS HAVING ON THEIR
ECONOMIES ENVIRONMENT AND
COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL SPONSORED I'M COUNTY
MONTEREY AND SUPPORT BY RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THE FARM
BUREAU HAS MADE A LOT OF
OPPOSITION TO THE SENATORS MAJOR
THE CENTER APPRECIATES THE
CONVERSATIONS OFFICES HAD WITH
THE BURIAL AND THE STAFF IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
FARM BUREAU ON LANGUAGE. TO
AMEND THE MAJOR IN THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME IS.
HEARING IS ALSO THE COUNTY HAVE
CULTURES COMMISSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OUT MY
NAME IS HENRY GONZALEZ AND I I
SERVE AS AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER FOR THE COUNTY OF
OF MODERATE I'M HERE. TO TO
ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO TO VOTE IN THE AFFIRMATIVE --
THE THE GOOD AGRICULTURAL CODE
REQUIRES AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO REPORT ON ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS ON THE CONDITION
ACREAGE.
PRODUCTION AND VALUE OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS IN.
IN EACH OF OUR RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES.
CANNABIS NOW IS A AS A COMMODITY
IS IS UP FAST AND AND GROWING A
NO PUN INTENDED.
AS AS A AS A NEW COMMODITY IT
THE IT ADDS TO THE DIVERSITY OF
COMMODITIES THAT EACH COUNTY
GROWS FROM MONTEREY COUNTY THAT
IS DEFINITELY. ONE OF OUR
ECONOMIC STRAINS IS THE
DIVERSITY OF CROPS WE HAVE OVER
ONE HUNDRED CROPS THAT ALL
GENERATE OVER.
A MILLION DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR TWENTY SEVENTEEN A FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS A 4% INCREASE OVER TWENTY
SIXTEEN I JUST YESTERDAY I
RELEASED VIA THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT. TO THE A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I HAVE A COUPLE
OF WELL AND I CAN FOR THAT
PROVIDE MORE COPIES IF AS YOU
WOULD LIKE OUT.
OF RIGHT NOW MONTEREY COUNTY
WE'RE ESTIMATING WHERE EITHER
THE FOURTH OR FIFTH --
LARGEST STOCK CANNABIS PRODUCER --
IN IN THE STATE AND AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING INTO
THAT NUMBER ONE SLOT --
OVER TIME ON BUT IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TO US CURRENTLY WE ARE
ALLOWING CANNABIS TO BE TO BE
GROWN.
IN EITHER --
EXISTING OR PREVIOUSLY EXISTING
GREENHOUSES.
IT'S INTERESTING PERHAPS THAT.
OUR OUR CUT FLOWER GROWERS IN
MONTEREY COUNTY OF LOST THEIR
BUSINESSES IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE WAR ON DRUGS [inaudible]
AND SUBSIDIES --
TO TO GROWERS IN IN --
SOUTH AMERICA AND IN HERE NOW
WERE ARE.
ABLE TO TO REKINDLE THOSE THOSE
LOCATIONS BACK --
TO I'LL A LEGAL COMMODITY --
IN CANADA SO I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO OF ALL TO A TO VOTE AND
ANDY IN THE AFFIRMATIVE.
AND MAY I APPROACH YOU WITH THE
COPIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PULSE WITH WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I JUST REAL COUPLE QUICK OF
QUICK POINTS --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF KEY MEMBERS
IN OUR ASSOCIATION THAT HAVE
EMBRACED CANNABIS INCREDIBLES
CULTIVATION AND WITHOUT WILL
COME SOON BY HEAVY DUTY
MARKETING AND BRANDING --
AND SO HAVING THE DATA ABOUT OF
THIS IN THE CROP REPORT REVEALS
GOING TO BE VERY BENEFICIAL TO
THOSE MEMBERS OF RC RC WHO HAVE
EMBRACED THIS COMMODITY.
ALSO REALLY WANT TO APPLAUD AND
THINK THIS ON THIS BILL AS IT
RELATES TO THE DISCRETION THE
BILL PROVIDES --
THE AG COMMISSIONERS AND COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
DEVELOPING THIS IN THE CROP
REPORT AUG ACCUSERS DO NOT EVEN
HAVE TO DO THIS AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN.
THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE LISTED
IN THE BILL OF THEY ARE A
DISCRETIONARY IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU WOULD REPORT THIS WHERE YOU
WOULD REPORT THAT.
WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL
THAT WILL HELP THOSE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE EMBRACED CANNABIS --
AS A MAJOR --
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY IN THEIR
REGION I THINK IT ALSO HELPED
THE STATE AS WE MOVE FORWARD A
WITH THE UNFOLDING OF THIS
REGULATORY SCHEMES WE ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I SHOULD JUST SAT DOWN AYE HAS
ACCOUNT OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AYE
REPRESENTING ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
I'M MOSTLY LICENSED NOW CANNABIS
CARS AND BUSINESSES.
THRILLED TO HEAR THAT OUT
MONTEREY COUNTY IS GOING TO TAKE
A RUN AT THE LEAD PRODUCER I
STRONG SUPPORT THINK COLLECTING
THIS INFORMATION PUBLISHING IT
IS GONNA BE A GREAT STEP FORWARD
FOR ALL OF US THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
IF YOU'RE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR RUSSIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE MISTER FLORA
BIKES ENTRANCE SENATOR CAL'S
GOING TO USE TO WORK WITH US
ALONG WITH THE SPONSORS THAT
WILL BE REMOVING OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
I'M AND THERE'S AN AMENDMENT
THAT THAT.
THAT --
SENATOR WILL BE TAKING IN
REGARDS TO THIS SIR.
IS IT IS IT SOMETHING WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT AND TALK ABOUT.
IN IN REGARDS TO THE FARM BUREAU.
PART OF IT SO WE HAVE ASKED THAT
AND THE LANGUAGE TERMINOLOGY BE
CHANGED TO ENSURE THAT CANNABIS
IS NOT CONFUSES AGRICULTURAL
COME.
THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL CODE
AND WE'VE ALSO ASKED FOR
PROVISION THAT WOULD PRECLUDE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS FROM
SEEKING REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
CROP REPORT FOR CANNABIS FROM
THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL FUND.
BUT THAT WOULD NOT RESTRICT THEM
FROM USING THE CAMPUS ON FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
S THERE ANYONE.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGMAN QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MATHIS I I THINK MISTER FLORA
ONE IN RESPONSE TO THE AMENDMENT --
IF IF WE CAN HEAR YOUR TAKE BACK
ON THAT.
YOU'RE NOT JUST --
ECHOING THE SENATORS PAM
COMMITMENT TO CAN YOU WORK WITH
THE FARMING IN THE FARM BUREAU
HAVE IN THE POLAR OPPOSITIONAL
BIG PART OF THIS CITY IS
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO TO
WORKING WITH THEM AS THIS THING
PROGRESSES SO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
THE GOOD SO THAT WAS THAT WAS MY
CONCERN WAS WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WITH THE FARM BUREAU.
OF THAT BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
COMMITMENT BETWEEN YOURSELF AND
THE SENATOR TO WORK WITH THEM --
THE IN FROM WHAT I'M SEEING THIS
GIVES A LOT OF LOCAL CONTROL.
WHICH I KNOW IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR US AND OUR
AGRICULTURAL INTEREST --
ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY GROWS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY --
DEPEND WHETHER IT SO GLAD TO SEE
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING WITH THAT
AND SO FOR THAT REASON ALSO
PARADE MOVING FOR THE DAY.
A LOOK FLORIDA SCENE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ARE IF YOU NEED HELP
YOU KNOW WHERE TO FIND ME.
ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
IF NOT I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
INTO.
THREE YOU'RE RIGHT WE CAN'T YET
WELL WE NEED ONE MORE PERSON
PEAK WHEN. TWO MORE PEOPLE.
OKAY SO WELL WAIT UNTIL WE GET A
QUORUM AND THEN WE'LL TAKE IT UP
THEN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
BELFER CENTER CANNELLA
[inaudible] SIX NO THAT'S RIGHT
I FORGOT I FORGOT WE NEED ONE
MORE
[inaudible]
BETTER
DECLINE
.
AND MY VERY FIRST MINUTE --
THE MOMENT IN RULES COMMITTEE
AND WE WE HAVE A HIGH PROFILE
PERSON WERE INTERVIEWING AND
THEN I WALKED OUT ON BECAUSE YOU
GUYS ARE WAY MORE MPORTANT.
SO.
I CAN GIVE THIS BILL I MEAN I I
BUY HER SUPPORT SUPPORT HOW MUCH
DOES A CHAIR WANNA KNOW CAUSE
I'M GONNA DEFERRED AND WELL I
USUALLY ASK THAT MEMBERS TO WAIT
UNTIL THERE'S A PRESENTATIONS
JUST.
KIND OF OUT OF DECORUM BUT IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE IT SHORT WAY
WE'D BE HAPPY TO HEAR IT.
GREAT WELL AGAIN --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AS BEFORE TO KNOW NINE WILL.
WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW TO
STREAMLINE THE PRODUCTION
CULTIVATION OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT HIP IS GROWN IN OVER
THIRTY NATIONS AND I'D NINETY
NINETEEN STATES.
IT HAS IMMENSE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
IS INDUSTRIAL HEMP IS USED IN
ALL KINDS OF PRODUCTS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS ME --
GREAT CROP FOR CALIFORNIA AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE NO STRANGER TO
DROUGHT LIKE CONDITIONS IN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
HAS A POTENTIAL THIS TO SAVE.
A LOT OF WATER IN MY PARTICULAR
DISTRICT NUMBER ONE CROP HIS
ALFALFA THAT TAKES SEVEN ACRE
FEET OF WATER PER ACRE
INDUSTRIAL HEMP IS ANYWHERE
BETWEEN ONE POINT SEVEN TO TO TO
ACRE FEET OF WATER.
ADDITIONALLY TAKES LITTLE TO NO
PESTICIDES.
AND AND BECAUSE IT IS DEEP ROOTS
IT REGENERATES THE SOIL.
I AT ONE POINT WE WERE
CALIFORNIA WAS WELL POSITION
WHEN WE ENACTED SP FIFTY OF FIVE
SIXTY SIX WE SENATOR LENO BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHICH INSTEAD
WHICH IS STATUS IN INTERNATIONAL
HEMP FARMING PROGRAM.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY PROP SIXTY
FOUR CONTAIN PROVISIONS THAT
LARGELY AND DID MUCH OF THAT
PROGRESS BY LUMPING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP THAT OR CULTURAL COMMODITY.
WITH IS INTOXICATING COUSIN
CANNABIS --
SP FOUR TWO AND I WANT TO GET
FOR CALIFORNIA AT THE LEADING
EDGE OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTION.
CAN PROVIDE OUR FARMERS WITH THE
REAL WATER SAVING ALTERNATIVE
CROPS LIKE CORN AND ALFALFA.
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
CALIFORNIA'S INDUSTRY SECTOR. TO
CREATE ENERGY ROADS --
SKINS A CARS AND SO MUCH MORE.
IN ADDITION I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
A CONCERN RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS PERTAINING TO
THE OPT OUT PROVISION IN THE
BILL.
IS NOT OUR INTENT TO LIMIT OUR
BAND THE GROWING OF HIP IN ANY
WAY.
THE PROVISION THAT WE ACCEPT IT
WAS AMENDED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. TO LIVE ALLEVIATE ANY
CONCERNS IN TERMS OF IT BEING
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE.
THE PROVISION IS AIM TO CLARIFY
THAT IT'S ONLY FOR CROSS
POLLINATION CONCERNS IN A ROOM
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO SUCCESSFULLY
THREAD THAT NEEDLE --
IS THUS FAR S. B. FORTINO NINE
IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN WITH
THAT RESPECT TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND JOIN ME TODAY'S PRAYER --
DARROW REPRESENTING VOTE HAND
AND HIGH ENERGETICS.
AGAIN I COULD INTERRUPT VERY
QUICKLY WE FINALLY HAVE A QUORUM
SO IF I COULD TAKE ROLE THAT
WOULD BE TERRIFIC.
MADAM THE ROLL CALL PLEASE
HEAVIER OUT HERE MATHIS HERE.
AND YEAR CURRY FLORA
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER LEVINE [inaudible]
SALAS.
VERY GOOD WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
YOU MODES MOTION WITH THE BILL
THERE IS A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL [inaudible]
SIR SECOND.
THE HURT HERE OKAY.
YOU MAY PROCEED ALRIGHT MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS BRADBURY WAS
VOTE HEMP AND I'LL BE BRIEF THE
SENATE IS VERY THOROUGH JOB OF
RUNNING THROUGH THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL.
I WILL SAY THIS IS A SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
CALIFORNIA WAS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS --
CERTAIN ACTIONS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL STATE LEVEL HAVE PUT US A
BIT BEHIND IN THIS BILL TO
RECTIFY THAT ENABLE CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER IN
THIS ASPECT.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE CO
AT CALVARY DEPARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE ON THIS BILL AND
WITH AND I WOULD URGE YOUR SIN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AFTER THAT CHAIR JASON RIGHT OF
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE WORK
THE AUTHORS DOWN ON THE BILL WE
ARE SPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER COMPUTER THE ARMY HALF
OF THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
INTERPOL SMITH WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES ASSOCIATIONAL WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL SUPPORT NOW I JUST
WANTED TO SEE IT ON THE RECORD
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS THAT OF
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
SENATORS AUTHOR OF SENATORS
OFFICE IS THE ISSUE OF THE ROLE
OF LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT IN THE CONVERSATIONS
OF HEMP ARMOR PLEASE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND HOPEFULLY WHEN
THE RESULT WILL BE IN SUPPORT
SUCH AS ONE OF THE STATE THAT
FOR THE RECORD.
I THINK IT.
SO ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PRIME DOT TO SEE ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ABBAS COALITION AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MINORITY ALLIANCE
INLAND EMPIRE CHAPTER WE ARE
CONTINGENT NEEDS ESPECIALLY BASE
ON HIS BILL WE WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO AMEND
SOME OF THE THINGS WITHIN
SECTION.
ONE AND SECTION PART WHICH SEEM
TO LIMIT AND RESTRICT FREE
ACCESS AS WELL AS FREE
ENTERPRISE WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH STAFF TO PROCEED WITH THAT
AT THE BILL ADVANCES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
THEN MOVE ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
CANNABIS COALITION ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPANK CHAMBER
COMMERCE IN THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CHAMBER COMMERCE --
ONE TENTH OF AN ACRE JUST NOT
ENOUGH.
OTHER SHOWS SHUT DOWN IN THE
THIRTIES BY BIG PHARMA AND PICK
COTTON --
THIS IS A BIG MONEY MAKER AS AN
ECONOMIC DRIVER WE NEED TO THINK
BIGGER --
LET'S.
LET'S STUDY LISTEN LET'S
COMMERCIALIZES BASS WAS POSSIBLE
THANK.
WE'VE VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SINGMAN ALL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE HAVE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
YES.
REALLY.
YEAH WHAT IS THE RIGHT TALK OFF
ALPHA IN YOUR DISTRICT WHICH IS
CLEARLY NOT THE RIGHT --
CLIMB IT --
FOR GROWING ALFALFA BUT YOU KNOW
WE DO AMAZING THINGS WATER TO IT
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO GROW
THEIR WHAT WE'RE WOOD.
NON.
AND BE GROWN IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THE IT THE IDEAL PLACES FOR THAT.
IT CAN BE GROWN IS BASICALLY A
WEED SO IT CAN REALLY BE GROWN
LITERALLY ANYWHERE --
WHICH IS WHAT WOULD WHICH Y.
MAKES IT SO ATTRACTIVE I THINK
THERE'S A LARGE SWATHS OF LAND
IN.
IN ASSEMBLYMAN SALAS IS DISTRICT
THAT COULD CONVERT FROM COTTON --
TO TED TO HAND AND THE THING
ABOUT THAT YOU CAN USE THE WHOLE
EVEN USE ENTIRE PLAN FOR SO MANY
PRODUCTS.
AND SO I KNOW --
THIS BILL ACTUALLY CAME TO ME
FROM MY LOCAL FARMERS THE LA
COUNTY FARM BUREAU HAS ENDORSED
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THEY CAME BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
BECAUSE THEY JUST GONNA GETTING
WATER RIGHTS AND AT THAT
COMMITTEE WAS A BIG LOSER AND
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR WATER
SUPPLY CUT BY 44% OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
THEY CAN'T SUSTAIN AN
AGRICULTURAL LIFESTYLE DOING
ALFALFA SO THEY WANT TO CONFER --
TED TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP AND THEN
I'VE HAD MANUFACTURES A CALM
THAT SAY HEY.
IF IF THIS LIKE PASSES WE ARE
GOING TO COME AND WE'RE GONNA
PUT FACTORIES IN YOUR DISTRICT
BECAUSE WE WANT THAT BECAUSE NOW
THEY IMPORTED FROM OUT OF STATE --
THAT'LL BE ABLE TO SAVE THEM
SAVE THEM COSTS I THINK I'VE
SEEN AS A WIN WIN.
NXP COMMENTS ON THE SCALE OF
FARMING THAT WOULD BE ENGAGED IN
THE US --
I'M I'M I'M HAPPY I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE WE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS.
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THAT THAT
DIALOGUE BECAUSE AGAIN.
I I COULD BE WRONG I THINK LONG
TERM DID THIS IS A MORE OF MUCH
MORE LUCRATIVE --
CROP TO GROW THEN THEN CANNABIS
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS PARTICULAR CROP AND IT
DON'T MEAN TO SPEAK FOR YOU BUT
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO A NUMBER OF
HEMP GROWERS IN MY LOCAL REGION
IS WHILE AND IT'S GOT.
IT'S GOT MANUFACTURING
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE PRETTY
WIDESPREAD AND SO THE ABILITY TO
USE IT IN.
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT --
APPLICATIONS MEANS THAT YOU
COULD ACTUALLY MANUFACTURE
THINGS WITH IT --
SO I THINK IT'S GOT IN AND WHAT
I'M PARTICULARLY EXCITED ABOUT
AND I LIKE TO BE LISTED AS A CO
AUTHOR ABSOLUTELY.
EVER DO AN AMENDMENT BUT THE
PIECE THAT I'M EXCITED ABOUT IS
THAT -- IT'S
GOT APPLICATIONS AS A FOOD
PRODUCT AS A FIBRE.
AS THE IT EVIDENTLY YOU CAN MAKE
IT INTO ALMOST LIKE A FIBERGLASS
TAKE OUT OF OF MATERIAL.
AND THE ABILITY TO HAVE --
THAT IT IT IS GROWN IN.
IS I THINK PARTICULARLY EXCITING
IS PARTICULARLY AS WE LOOK AT
SOME OF THE NITRATE ISSUES IN
THAT TREE.
CONTAMINATION YOU CAN BRING UP
THAT WATER PUT IT ON THE GROUND
OR TAKE IT OUT OF THE GROUND.
AND UP AND DO CLEAN UP IN A WAY
THIS RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE SOAP
BUT YEAH THAT'S GREAT MEN
ATTRACTED TO THE POINT THAT I
WANTED TO TO GET TO WERE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION --
THAT LIKE TO DO ALL THE BENEFITS
THAT YOU FIND COULD BE POSSIBLE.
WITH THIS B. BROWN OF THE SCALE
ATTACKS WE HARNESS THOSE
BENEFITS AND DAD IN AND WHY ARE
THOSE CONCERNS OUT THERE.
I DO WITH THAT THE LAST GROUP
I'VE NOT I HAVE NOT SPOKEN WITH
THIS THE FIRST TIME I'M HEARING
IT'S I DON'T KNOW THEY'VE.
SPOKEN MY STAFF NOT IT NOT AWARE.
BUT YOU COULD GO MASKING ALSO
LIKE IF YOU PURCHASE A BMW
THAT'S MANUFACTURED IN EUROPE
THE SKINS IS MADE OUT OF HIT
BECAUSE THE FIBER SO STRONG SO
LIGHT SO IT IS LIKE FIBERGLASS.
HOW THEY DON'T USE CONCRETE IN
EUROPE THEY USE HIM CREATE IS
STRONGER THAN CONCRETE AND IT'S
A QUESTIONS CAR BEEN?
YEAH OUT THERE USING THE FIBER
IN CANADA FOR FOR BUILDING
INSULATION BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT THE TEMPERATURE IS
OUTSIDE IT'S SEVENTY DEGREES
INSIDE ALL THE TIME.
ON TOP OF ALL THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT THAT WE KNOW ABOUT SO A LOT
OF MANUFACTURING --
OPPORTUNITIES WITH WITH HIM.
SO WHERE YOU WHERE YOU IT ASKING
THE QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THE
BILL THAT LIMITS.
THERE'S LIMITATIONS UPON MATH
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALUM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LIMITATION I I WAS
JUST.
ASKING TO HAVE CLARIFICATION ON
WHAT THE OPPOSITION BUT YEAH
THAT THAT'S ALL YOU KNOW I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
BILL I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT.
YOU FOR FROM OUR UNDERSTANDING
AYE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
SUPPORTING AYE THAT TENTH OF AN
ACRE LIMITATION IS FROM THE LENO
LEGISLATION THAT'S B. FIVE SIXTY
SIX FROM A FEW YEARS AGO AND
ACTUALLY PART OF THE REFORM
THAT'S TAKING PLACE HERE IS
REMOVING SOME OF THOSE
LIMITATIONS.
AND BRINGING STATE LAW INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL LAW AND
THAT SORT OF OPENING THE GATES
HERE.
THANK YOU JOHN YEAH ONE OF THE
THINGS BECAUSE THIS WAS GOING
THROUGH IT TED TO ACCOMMODATE
YOU IS IT THAT WE ALSO ARE
TAKING ALL THE UPDATES HAT WERE
IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN FEDERAL FARM ACT.
SO IN THE OTHER THIS INTERESTING
SO ABOUT A MONTH AGO IN THIS
HARD TO BELIEVE BUT SENATOR
MCCONNELL.
AND SENATOR SCHUMER ACTUALLY
JOINTLY AUTHORED A BILL TO MAKE
INDUSTRIAL HAPPEN AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS SET A SCHEDULE.
ONE SO THIS OF THIS MOVING VERY
FAST AND WE WILL I THINK WE WANT
TO BE OUT FRONT ON IT.
SO WE CAN HAVE OUR OUR FARMERS
GROWING AND THAT OUR
MANUFACTURERS COMING IN BEHIND
IT.
IT'S GREAT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD --
OKAY I THINK THEIR WORDS AND IT
IT AN ADDITION ONTO A COMMENT.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
REBUTTAL JUST TO THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE TRIED TO SPEAK WITH YOUR
STAFF ESPECIALLY PERTAIN TO THIS
BILL MULTIPLE DIME SO PERHAPS IF
YOU COULD RECOLLECT WITH THEM
LOCKED UP RIGHT NOW.
ABSOLUTELY AND WHAT I LIKE TO
SAY ESPECIALLY IS WHY THE MAIN
CONCERNS IS THAT IS SCRIPTED
WITH SOME LANGUAGE FROM MAC
FEDERAL MANDATES BECAUSE ONCE
YOU GO INTO A FEDERAL MANDATE
UNLESS.
FOR CLARIFYING WITH WHAT WAS
JUST DECIDE BY THE FDA NAMED
WERE EVEN DOING WITH THAT WITH
CANNABIS AND BANKING CABS AND
TAXATION ONCE YOU START BUYING
THE WATER'S TOO MUCH WITH THE
LANGUAGE IN THE PROVISIONS THAT
ARE IN FEDERAL COMPLIANCE.
THEN THAT'S WHERE WE AS A STATE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH OBVIOUSLY
UNLESS IT'S TAKING OFF OUR
UNIFORM CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
ACCESO FOR RIGHT NOW WE THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE MANY CONCERNS WE
HAVE.
IS TO STAY WITH THEM WHAT
OBVIOUSLY IS WE OUGHT TO BE
STIPULATED WITH COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS AS A WHOLE MAJESTIC
KEEP THAT CONSISTENCY IN THAT
LEVEL FOR WHAT WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW AS SO THANK YOU FOR MY
COMMENT THANK YOU.
SHE TO VERY MUCH.
YEAH SENATOR HAVE DOES NOT KILL
YOU YOU MAKE YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
YEAH AGAIN --
AT THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION.
AND INDUSTRIAL HIM IS IS THAT AS
AS AMERICAN AS HOT DOGS BASEBALL
AND APPLE PIE THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS BETSY ROSS WE'VE HER
FIRST FLAG OUT OF HIM.
WHEN THOMAS JEFFERSON WAS
DRAFTING THE WE AT THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE HE
DID THAT ON HEMP PAPER?
SO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS BRING
BRING AMERICA BACK TO ITS FUTURE
AND THAT'S THAT'S INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AS NOTED SIX BY SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
THAT WE CAN HAVE HERE IN OUR
STATE SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
SO WILL TAKE THEIR OF S. B.
FOURTEEN ON NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO PROCREATION.
COMEY ROI CALMLY ARE ALL I
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE PHONE CALL SO THAT
WILL PUT THE BILL ON COLUMN WILL
WAIT TO THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE
HERE THEY ARE NOT SURE MEMBERS
OFFICIATING.
SO -- CAN I
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
[inaudible]
I DON'T.
MET MOTION IS MADE AND SECONDED
TO CONSENT ITEMS ARE EASIER.
TO SEVENTEEN AND S. B. TEN
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR PAT.
THE REAL PLACE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CAVALLARO I CALL THE
AIRLINE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE A YEAR CARRY.
FLORA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY -- WHEN?
JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN.
IT THAT BILL IT THAT THE THAT
CONTENT IS ON CALL AS WELL.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO ON IT ON OUR AGENDA WELCOME
SENATOR MCGUIRE HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU HERE WITH US.
THAT IS S. B. SIX SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS THE COMMERCIAL FEED BUT
IT VIOLATIONS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES.
I DON'T SHARE MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON NO IT'S A CRAZY WEEK
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
TO BE A TO PRESENT.
AN HONOR TO BE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL.
YOU'RE VERY KEEP STATUS HONESTLY
THINK YOU OUT FOR ALL THE WORK
ON BOTH OF THESE BILLS.
THE CALVET DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
NARAL CULTURES COMMERCIAL FEED
REGULATORY PROGRAM HELPS TO
ENSURE THAT THE MILK AND MEAT.
ARE SOLD IN THIS.
SAFE AND CLEAN.
I WASI DEFACE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED TO TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION ON ANIMAL FEED
MANUFACTURERS THAT KNOWINGLY OR
REPEAL OF THE THAT PRODUCE
ADULTERATED FEED.
THE CURRENT FINE STRUCTURE
CANDIDLY IN PLACE FOR VIOLATIONS
OF THE COMMERCIAL FEEDLOT IS
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TO BE AVERAGE
HER OFFENDERS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO ARE REPEAT. TO DETER FUTURE
VIOLATIONS DEFEAT INSPECTION
ADVISORY BOARD RECOMMENDED TO
CDFA.
I SAID THAT THEY DOT STRONGER
PENALTIES AND ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS.
ON IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
AGAIN EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THERE SUGGESTED LANGUAGE IS
REFLECTED IN THIS BILL MOST
IMPORTANTLY SP SIX SIXTY EIGHT
INCREASES PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATORS AND ALLOWS TO BE
AFRAID TO ISSUE ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES INSTEAD OF CIVIL
PENALTIES.
AS MANY.
THAT MANY OF YOU HERE HAVE
AGRICULTURE TIES YOU KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING ABLE SURE
THE QUALITY FEE TO BUYERS.
S. B. SIX SIXTY EIGHT PROVIDES A
STRONGER FINANCIAL TO TURN TO
ENSURE THAT CDFA CAN CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THE QUALITY FEET SOLD.
AND STOP THOSE WHO INTENSELY
SKIRT ARE VITAL COMMERCIAL FEET
LAST.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT MR ALBION IS
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF CAFFEINE
GREEN FEET ASSOCIATION WE ARE
TOLD WE ALSO HAVE RACHEL O'BRIEN%
THE ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF CDFA
TO BETTER PROVIDE A IN SUPPORT
ON TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
BUT I'M SURE AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THERE IS A MOTION IS OUR
SECOND.
THERE'S A MOTION SECOND YOU MAY
PROCEED DENNIS ALBION AB HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED
ASSOCIATION OF THE AND ASKED THE
SENATOR MENTIONED WERE OBVIOUSLY
A TRADE ASSOCIATION WORK RIVER
CLOSE IN SEVERAL MEMBERS ARE ON
THE PUMP ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN
THE REASON THIS BILL COME SO
LATE.
IS THAT THERE WAS DISCUSSIONS
FOR LAST YEAR ABOUT A YOU KNOW
INCREASING PENALTIES.
AND MOVED TO ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROPOSAL ACTUALLY
WENT THROUGH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH IS A YOU KNOW.
GOVERNMENTAL ADVISORY ENTITY A
APPOINTED BY THE SECRETARY.
THAT.
OCCURRED THEY HAD VIGOROUS
DISCUSSION OVER THAT THE
SPECIFICS OF ANY MOVE FROM CIVIL
TO ADMINISTER PANELS AND AND AND
ALL POLICIES THERE SO WHY WOULD
WE SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW INCREASE PENALTIES ON
OUR ON OUR ENTITIES WILL THE
GOAL IS TO GET BETTER COMPLIANCE
PLAN LAW.
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE HAT ARC
FOLLOWING LAW DIDN'T DO THAT AND
AND REGULARLY BUT ALSO TRY TO
BRING.
THE FOLKS THAT ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE INTO COMPLIANCE AND
CREATE AN APPROPRIATE INCENTIVE
TO GET INTO COMPLIANCE --
WE DO HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
THAT THE BRANCH ANIMAL --
HEALTH BRANCH THAT YOU SEE
PENALTIES.
BUT THE IDEAS IN REGULATION THEY
WILL PUT TOGETHER A MATRIX THAT
SHOWS SAY OF A PAPERWORK
VIOLATION IS FAR LESS.
THE MAXIMUM AND AND PUT IN A
MATRIX OF MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS
LEAD TO THE MAXIMUM.
AND THOSE GUYS SO WE DO WE DO IN
VISION AND REGULATION A A MATRIX
THAT WILL GRADE.
THE VIOLATIONS AS WELL AS THE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS TO GET TO
THOSE MAXIMUM SO THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
VERY GOOD IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WELL IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
AT BRING THAT UP ISSUE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT ES I
UNDERSTAND THE LIKE --
MYSTERY AVIANO JUST STATED AND
YOU KNOW IT'S RIGHT WHEN THE
INDUSTRY COMES TOGETHER AND SAYS
LOOK WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO MAKE SURE OUR PEOPLE ARE
PLAYING BY THE RULES --
IN IN SENATOR YOU'VE TAKEN THE
SAWN IN THE CRAFTSMANSHIP OF YOU
TO PUTTING THIS TOGETHER.
A WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY FOR
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS AND AND FOR
MYSELF COMING FROM A VERY BIG AG
AREA THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN --
GETTING BAD FEEDSTOCK.
ON THE IN THE FRUSTRATION THAT
COMES WITH IT TO SELL IT TO SEE
THIS BILL FOR IS ACTUALLY.
VERY THING.
BY WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT ON
THE FLOOR.
WE AGREE FROM SAMANTHA STINKY SO
MUCH GRIEF FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SO WHEN I THINK YOU MISTER A
REALITY FOR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
BECAUSE I WANTED SOMEONE AGREE
IT'S A LOT EASIER WHEN THE
INDUSTRY COMES FORWARD AND I'VE.
GENERALLY I DON'T SUPPORT A BIG
JUMP IN FINES I'M MOSTLY BECAUSE
AND IT.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A GRADATION.
WHERE YOU CAN GET IT HAVE?
BASICALLY PARKING TICKET FOR
MAKING A MISTAKE THEN IT IT
REALLY STARTS TO PENALIZE
BUSINESSES IN A WAY THAT I THINK
IS NOT REALLY PRODUCTIVE BUT THE
FACT THAT THIS WAS.
TAKE INTO ADVISORY COMMITTEE OR
CAME THROUGH THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THAT THEY EVEN
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IT'S A GOOD
THING -- SO
I AM ALSO GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
THAT BEING SAID --
WILL DO THE ROLL CALL.
S. B. SIX FIXATE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COMEY OUR
OWN AYE CAMBIADO AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AG YEAR CURRY
[inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE AYE AYE LEVINE AYE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN OF SO THAT BILL WILL
BE ON CALL AS WELL.
THE RETURNING MEMBERS OR IS THAT
MEMBERS THAT HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THERE YET CAN SHOW UP IN.
VOTERS ROTH I'M THE LAST ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS S. B.
NINE SIXTY FIVE MISTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON BOTH THESE BILLS.
THE GOLDEN STATE'S CATTLE MARKET
IS ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE IN
THE NATION.
WITH SMALL FAMILY ORGANIC
FARMERS IN LARGER PRODUCERS WHO
SERVE CONSUMERS WITH A RANGE OF
TASTES.
I AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA DOES
BUSINESS A BIT DIFFERENTLY THAN
OTHER STATES AND IS THAT
DIFFERENCE HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE THAT CALIFORNIA CATTLE
FAMILIES ARE PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT THERE THE LEADING THE
NATION REDUCING THEIR CARBON
FOOTPRINT.
WE'VE DISTRICT IS CLEAN AIR AND
WATER LAWS IN AMERICA RIGHTFULLY
SO.
IN CALIFORNIA'S CATTLE RANCHES
AND AREAS ARE TACKLING CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FOR THE FUTURE
OF THE STATE.
IN THEIR INDUSTRY.
THAT SAID CALIFORNIA'S CATTLE
RANCHERS ARE DISADVANTAGED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE AN
ABILITY TO TELL THE STORY TELLER
STORY OF AN INDUSTRY THAT IS
DOING RIGHT BY THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND GIVING THE CONSUMER A CHOICE
AT THE DEMAND.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A STATE
ENTITY TO BE ABLE TO PROMOTE OR
CONDUCT RESEARCH SPECIFICALLY.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CATTLE
INDUSTRY.
THIS WOULD BE SIMILAR TO WHAT
ALREADY EXISTS WITH OTHER
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE FOR EXAMPLE
FRUITS AND VEGGIES.
I WHO HAVE THEIR OWN CD NITTY.
IT'S BEEN NINE SIXTY FIVE ALLOWS
FAMILY CATTLE RANCHERS THE RIGHT
TO VOTE DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLE COUNCIL.
WHICH WILL UTILIZE FUNDS
COLLECTED THROUGH A REFUNDABLE
ASSESSMENT OF ONE BOOK PER HEAD
OF CATTLE SPECIFICALLY FOR
CATTLE RESEARCH.
EDUCATION AND PROMOTION ON THE
RAISING OF CALIFORNIA BEEF AND
DAIRY.
OUR BIGGEST STRENGTH.
OUR DIVERSE CATTLE MARKET.
WITH OUR SMALL FAMILY FARMERS A
LARGE PRODUCERS HIGHLIGHTS A
GREATER NEED FOR THE SPATE THE
STATE'S PACIFIC RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION.
THEY NEED ENHANCE RESEARCHING
HOW THEY CAN MINIMIZE THE
IMPACTS ON WATER SUPPLY THROUGH
A DROUGHT OR HOW.
TO FURTHER REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS S. B. NINE SIXTY FIVE
IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING THAT WE
GIVE OUR CATTLE PRODUCERS THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO THRIVE.
IN THE EVER CHANGING INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL ROUS AS WE SEE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WILL NOT
RESULT IN ANY ADDITIONAL STATE
COSTS REALLY GRATEFUL MADAM%
CHAIR THAT WE HAVE. TWO
FANTASTIC FAMILY CATTLE RANCHERS
HERE WE'VE CODING NICHOLSON
STRATTON A SMALL FAMILY RANCHER
A FOGGY BOTTOM FARMS AND LOVES
JERSEYS MY GOODNESS IN AND OUT
WILL NOT A SHOWING THE FOR
HOSTING --
HE IS FROM AT FERNDALE AND FOR
THE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF HIS WORK
ON THIS.
AND ALSO VERY GRATEFUL THAT WE
HAVE CHERYL THE FRANKIE.
A PURE BRED AND GRASS FINISH
CATTLE PRODUCER FROM SONOMA
COUNTY BREAK REFERENCE OF
THINKING THAT YOU'RE HERE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH BOTH OF YOU.
LIFE WOULD BE OKAY TO HAVE
WITNESSED SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY.
COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIRPERSON I AM
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
START WITH AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT UP MY NAME IS CHERYL OF
FRANKIE AND I AM SUPPORTING THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLE.
OF PEOPLE AND WE ARE SUPPORTING
S. B. --
NINE SIXTY FIVE I HAVE A AT
MODEST SIZED FAMILY CATTLE RANCH
THAT I OWN AND RUN IT'S BEEN IN
THE FAMILY NOW FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS WE'RE GOING ON THE
FOURTH GENERATION.
WE SAID IN THAT.
OF SOUTHEASTERN CORNER OF CINEMA
COUNTY.
AND I WILL SAY TO VERY BEAUTIFUL
AREA.
WE PRIDE THE MAYBE THE ONLY AND
THE BIGGEST CATTLE RANCH SURE
FOR MANY MILES AROUND US BUT
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT --
THOUGH LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY IN THE
CATTLE INDUSTRY CHANGE --
WE'VE CHANGED OUR CATTLE RANCH
WITH IT --
MY FATHER STARTED WITH AN FFA
PROJECT IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
WENT ON TO DEVELOP A VERY WELL
THOUGHT OF HER TO BEAR* COWS
WE'VE CHANGED TO BEEF CATTLE
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A IN A MORE
HILLY ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S MORE
SUITABLE. TO TO THE BEEF COWS IN
THE DAIRY COWS THAT WE HAD SO
WE'VE CHANGED TO BEEF CATTLE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND THEN
OVER THERE.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS.
WELL IT'S BEEN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
NOW WE'VE DEVELOPED A PROGRAM
WITH THE BEAR REPUBLIC BREWING
COMPANY --
WE'VE FEED THEIR SPENT GRAIN
WERE UP TO THIRTY THOUSAND
POUNDS A SPENT GREEN SIX DAYS A
WEEK.
THAT WE PICK UP FROM THEM SO
WHERE AN INTEGRAL PART OF THEIR
POPULAR OF THEIR PRODUCTION
FACILITY.
WE FEED THAT TO OUR CALVET WE'VE
NOW DEVELOPED A GONE A LITTLE
MORE TO THE NICHE MARKET --
WE APPRECIATE THIS BILL IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND BEHIND IT --
WE THINK ESPECIALLY BEING
VOLUNTARY --
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL THAT WE
CAN GET BEHIND IS CATTLE
PRODUCERS OF MANY OF THAT.
COUNTIES AND THAT THE CATTLE
PEOPLE WE HAVE I THINK THREE
HUNDRED OR SO ON BOARD TWENTY
TWO COUNTIES FIFTEEN DIFFERENT
SOCI ASIANS IN THE COUNTY SO.
SO WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL AND WE HOPE THAT YOU GUYS
WILL SUPPORT IT TOO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CRITICAL SINCE THREATEN MY
FAMILY OWNS AND OPERATES FOGGY
BOTTOM IS JERSEY DAIRY UP IN
FERNDALE AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY
WHERE A FAMILY OWNED AND
OPERATED ORGANIC.
AND PASTOR BASED AREA THAT'S
BEEN IN OPERATION SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTIES.
OUR MILD CLIMATE.
AND ALLOWS US TO RAISE OUR SMALL
HERD OF COWS ON PASTURE FULL
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS
ANNUALLY IN UTILIZING
PROGRESSIVE HOLISTIC PASTOR
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
PUTTING ROTATIONAL GRAZING
TARGETED STOCKING DENSITIES AND
UNDERSTAND PLANT COMMUNITIES AND
BIOLOGICAL PASSED AND WE'D
MANAGEMENT.
WE MANAGED TO IMPACT OUR LAND
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY.
BENEFICIAL MANNER TODAY I'M
SPEAKING TO YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
EIGHT HUNDRED MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA DAIRY INDUSTRY.
THAT WITH WESTERN UNITED DAIRY
MEN AND THE MANY INDIVIDUALS
THERE IS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BIT OF
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN THE NATION'S LEADING
DAIRY STATE.
RANKING FIRST IN THE US IN THE
PRODUCTION OF TOUCH.
NONFAT DRY MILK WAVE AND WE
PROTEIN CONCENTRATE.
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR DAIRY
PRODUCTS LIKE CHEESE AND YOGURT
AS WELL AS A STRONG VERY EXPORT.
ACCOUNTS FOR A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND JOBS THAT
ARE DEPEND ON THE STATE'S MILK
PRODUCTION AND PROCESSING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA DAIRY
PRODUCERS ARE THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY PROGRESSIVE IN
THE NATION ARE HELD TO A HIGHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ANIMAL HEALTH.
LAND AND WATER STANDARD THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY
OVER THE NEXT TWO DECADES THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY WILL BE REDUCING
ITS GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THROUGH S. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY 40%.
AND SENATE BILL NINE SIX FIVE
WOULD ALLOW DAIRY PRODUCERS TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH TO HELP THE
INDUSTRY CONTINUE TO MEET THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS STANDARDS WHILE
MAINTAINING ARE INDUSTRIES
ECONOMIC VIABILITY.
THIS LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED IT PROVIDES
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR DAIRY
PRODUCERS LIKE MYSELF. TO DECIDE
WHETHER NOT TO ASSESS THEMSELVES
IN CREATING THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLE COUNCIL.
ANY INDIVIDUAL PRODUCER LARGER
SMALL CONVENTIONAL OR ORGANIC
HAS ONE VOTE AND IF THE PRODUCER
WISHES TO NOT SUPPORT THE CATTLE
COUNCIL THEY CAN OBTAIN A REFUND
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
CALIFORNIA'S ORGANIZE DAIRY
PRODUCERS ARE FULLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE EFFORTS TO ESTABLISH THE
COUNCIL AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M AT THE ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
NO WELL KRAMER'S CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
IT IT HAS A CHI ALLEN AYE
RESIDENT OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY --
WATCHING THIS BILL VERY CLOSELY --
WITH AN AYE FOR HOW CAN HELP
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS IT'S AN
EXCITING WORK AND I AS A PERSON
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA PLEASED TO
SUPPORT A TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
NOT OPPOSITION ON THE SHUTTLE
LIKE OF ON BEHALF OF THE U.
COMMITS SIDE KNIGHTED STATES WE
WERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT
WANT TO THANK THE OFFICE OFFICE
AND SPONSOR FOR VERY.
COLLABORATIVE AND PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT TO
AMEND THE BILL --
TO REFERENCE GRASS FED INSTEAD
OF GRASS FINISHED AND ALSO A
SMALL CLARIFICATION THAT IT IS
NOT THE COUNCIL'S INTENT TO
ENGAGE IN LOBBYING ACTIVITIES.
WITH THOSE TWO AGREEMENTS THE
HUMAN SIDE OF UNITED STATES
WOULD REMOVE HIS OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. FOR ANYBODY THAT
JUST WANTS TO TALK.
KP SAYING NONE OF WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THE ONLY QUESTION I HAD IS
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE
BEEN AN OPT --
AB EIGHT IN OPT OUT FOR AN OPT
IN.
JUST SO THAT YOU'RE NOT HAVING
TO THE AYE AYE I UNDERSTAND ONE
OF THE CRITICISMS WAS --
GETTING HAVING READ THE REFUNDS
AND HOW THAT WOULD IT'S A
PROCEDURAL ISSUE MORE THAN
ANYTHING IT'S NOT.
DOESN'T AFFECT THAT THAT THE
BILL I THINK IT'S A I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN THE
INDUSTRY COMES FORWARD AND SAYS
LOOK WE'RE WILLING TO PAY --
A BUCKHEAD AND IN ORDER TO GET
THIS KIND OF WORK DONE I REALLY
APPRECIATED AND THAT'S VERY
POWERFUL --
I'M JUST WONDERING IF
PROCEDURALLY THERE'S A DO YOU.
TO DECIDE HOWEVER IT IS THAT.
MECHANICALLY IT WOULD WORK.
THERE WAS JUST AN OBJECTION AND
I WONDERED IF THERE WAS A BETTER
WAY TO DO IT.
NOT ABSOLUTELY IT'S IT'S AN ITEM
THAT I AM BEING VERY HONEST
MADAM CHAIR IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
QUITE A BIT --
IN THIS IS AN ITEM THAT
DIGESTION FOR EXAMPLE HAS BEEN
HOT TACKLING SINCE LAST YEAR.
WE BELIEVE.
THAT THIS IS THE BEST OPTION.
FOUR CAROL FAMILIES NO MATTER IF
YOU'RE DAIRY FARMER --
OR YEAR RAISING AYE CATTLE FROM
ME.
ON IT INSURERS AT MAXIMUM
PARTICIPATION.
AND I THINK THE PROVISION OF
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS WHO DON WHO
DO NOT ONE OF THE OTHER
PARTICIPATE A FULL REFUND.
AYE IS THE BEST APPROACH LONG
TERM FOR THIS INDUSTRY ABOUT
OUTLET AT JUSTIN ASSELIN TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK AS JUSTIN
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN --
AN HONEST BROKER ALL THE WAY
THROUGH IN WORKING WITH US IN SO
MANY HAD TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR --
AND MEMBERS COMMITTEE JUST ALL
FILLED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION.
EXCUSE ME --
SO I WOULD SAY QUICKLY FOR FOR
TWO REASONS ONE NO OTHER
COUNSELOR COMMISSION HAS AN OPT
IN PROVISION.
THAT IN FACT THERE'S ONE OTHER
THAT HAS A REFUND --
BUT SECOND IT'S LARGELY BASED ON
HOW OUR INDUSTRY WORKS --
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS OF OUR INDUSTRY IT'S
NOT VERTICALLY INTEGRATED LIKE
FARMING RETAKE THE PLAN OUT OF
THE FIELD TO THE CRAP OUT OF A
FIELD OF SLAVERY PACKAGE THAT.
CATALOG TRANSITION YOU KNOW --
OWNERSHIP MULTIPLE TIMES BEFORE
THEY'RE HARVESTED AND SO THAT
DOLLARS COLLECTED AT CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP --
WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT HOW THE
REFUND -- IN
PLACE BECAUSE THE REFUND CAN BE
HELD CONFIDENTIAL IF IT'S COMING
FROM THE CATTLE COUNCIL RATHER
THAN COMING FROM A PRIVATE
ENTITY IF WE WERE TO DO IT OFTEN
MOST CATTLE OR ARE YOU KNOW AS
THROUGH THIS TRANSITION PROCESS
ARE TAKEN TO A LIVESTOCK
AUCTIONEER.
AND ARE SOLD TO A PRIVATE ENTITY
A PRODUCER WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
THAT AUCTIONEER AND SAY I DON'T
WANT TO PAY FOR THIS SO WITH
HOLD MY MONEY.
AND ADOPT POINT TIME THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT CONFIDENTIAL
SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
REFUND PROVISION IS IMPORTANT.
WE EXPECT NOT A LOT OF PRODUCERS
TO USE IT BUT OUR FOLKS DO WANT
THAT BAILABLE WE THINK IT WOULD
BE DISINGENUOUS TO SAY.
YOU HAVE TO OUT YOURSELF IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IN THIS CASE EVEN GET THREE
FIVE CONFIDENTIAL.
AND YOU KNOW IT THAT THAT'S UP
TO YOU THERE'S O DISCOURAGING
AT TO USE IT AT THAT POINT
SOMEHOW THAT'S HELPFUL THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL I PREACH.
OVER THE BILL [inaudible]
IF YOU.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY MORE QUESTIONS ANY QUESTIONS.
IF NOT THE REPLACE.
ON SB NINE SIXTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASTURE PROCREATION KILEY
ARE I COULD BE OUR ALLY MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
A YEAR PERIOD AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SILENCE.
SALAS AYE WITH THEM.
GOES OUT.
GRADUATION THINK YOU'RE MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR THINKING
CONCURRENT FERNDALE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SO WE DO NEED A MOTION FOR ITEM
NUMBER SIX RELIGIOUS S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE CENTER
CANNELLA.
THE ROLE PLEASE YES.
SP FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CABALLERO AYE
COME BR I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER GRAY
[inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SILENCE.
SALAS SIGN PHILIP FOUND THAT
BILL IS OUT.
SO WE GOT WE'RE WE'RE DONE WITH
THE AGENDA ITEMS BUT WILL GO
AHEAD AND AND DO ADD ONS.
WE WE HAD WE WE DO IT.
ON LIFTING LIFTING THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE GALLAGHER.
GRAY.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I CAN THINK
COUNTERS ADOPTING CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
ON S. B. SIX SIX EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER --
JONES SAWYER AYE BILLS NOW THAT
BILL IS OUT.
ON S. B. FOURTEEN OWN NINE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER GRAY.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES PLAYER.
JONES SAWYER I VILLAGE OUT ALL
THOSE OUT AS WELL.
I THINK THOSE ARE.
ALL OF THE BILLS ARE OUT BUT
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR WHEN MORE AT ON THAT'S
IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
RIGHT
GALLAGHER I S. B. SIX SIX SAY
GALLAGHER
.
AND MAYBE I GALLAGHER I S. B.
NINE SIX FIVE GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER AYE.
S. B. FORTINO [inaudible]
NINE GALLAGHER I S. B. FOURTEEN
AND FIFTY NINE GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER NOW.
THAT CONCLUDES THE THE COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE WE ARE ADJOURNED
.
I DON'T LIKE [inaudible]
THERE'S I MISTER GALLAGHER THANK
YOU
[inaudible]
MIGRATED HERE [inaudible]
I WAS [inaudible]
DEFINITIONS [inaudible]
YES